this is a production of cornell
university
thank you larry for that introduction
and thanks to all of you guys
for for showing up to hear me give my
capstone seminar
so as larry said i um i have been
working
on uh mapping resistance to willow lee
for us in shrub willow i've been very
active
during my time here there have been um
i was fortunate enough to have a pretty
varied project so it kept things very
interesting
and i i hope that you uh think the same
um as i talk about what i've um my last
couple years here
at cornell so the title of my
presentation multiple approaches to
mapping resistance to melamp's relief
rust and shrub willow
so i have a few background slides before
i really get into it so
shrub willow is from the genus salix
the roughly 300 species with
ploidy levels ranging from diploid to
dodecaploid it can be grown for
biomass it also has fight over mediation
properties it can be used in
riparian buffers or it can be used
simply as a physical barrier like a snow
block for roadways
or you can even just google shrub willow
fence and you'll find some really really
interesting ways that people have woven
shrub willow together to create privacy
fences
and other like gazebo structures
it is dioecious so there are male and
female plants
and highly heterozygous uh and
commercially it's produced in what's
called a short rotation
compass system so what that means is
dormant cuttings they're like
eight to ten inches long are planted in
the spring
they're allowed to grow until the winter
when they go dormant again
and then they are cut back or coppiced
and this will cause the willow
to respond the next year with very
vigorous
heavily branched growth that's harvested
every two to three years
afterwards so you can imagine in
these really dense plantings that are in
the field for many many years
insects and pathogens can really get
into that field spread throughout it
take hold
and cause damage
one of the worst of which shocker
i know is will a leaf rust or melancera
it can lead to complete defoliation of
the plant which obviously will have a
downstream
effect on the total yield it is a
macrocyclic and heteroaches rest so in
terms of the rust family that means it
will go through
all five spore stages common to rust
this includes a sexual phase and it
requires
two hosts to complete its full life
cycle
so if we take a pathogen that has the
potential to
overwhelm resistance basically every
year
and we have a plant that could spend
20 plus years in the field you can start
to imagine how
that can be a real challenge to shrub
willow
breeders and producers to trying to find
durable long-lasting resistance
so in new york there are primarily two
main species of melancholams or
americana and melance
paradoxes but there are others who are
less prominent
as i kind of alluded to the management
strategies rely on pyramiding resistance
so trying to get as many resistance
genes into a single plant as possible
and even planting clonal mixtures so
instead of having a willow field
full of just one willow clone
they'll plant several different clones
in the hope of trying
to put less pressure on
diseases or insects to adapt to that
resistance to break that resist those
resistance genes
unfortunately most of the literature
well
it's not unfortunate for them it's
unfortunate for us most of the
literature focuses
on european species of melancera and
sailings so well we have there's a lot
to learn
from the work that's being done in
europe
but when it comes to things like will
hamster americana or salex purpurea
things are only generally applicable and
not very specific and those resistances
that they might have identified
in those european species of willow
don't
necessarily connect to what we have here
so with that in mind the research
objectives of
my predoc fellowship
in addition to the original usda grant
that i was on when i first got here
these research objectives the first
there are three of them
excuse me and the first was to leverage
the common parent f1 hybrid population
to map qtl for resistance with a leaf
rust
so obviously i need to tell you what the
common parent f1 hybrid population is
so to simply describe it you can think
of it
as there are eight f1 hybrid families
and there are essentially divided into
two half sib families there are four
um four female species all mated to the
male
salex preparing 9401 so that's
acidic vitamin alice integra celex
alberti and satruensis
while at the same time there are four
um males of different species mated to
the female
9406 salix for berea
so nine uh excuse me salex purporia was
chosen as the kind of the backbone
of this population one because it is a
naturalized species
to north america so that means although
it was not native
um it was brought here um from europe as
a basket willow
and it eventually gained such prevalence
that it could be found in the wild
so it's considered a naturalized species
in addition uh salex propria tends to be
resistant to
several pathogens and many of the
insects found around here
in addition to its aesthetic appeal on a
genomic standpoint
it is nine for six is also the most
um the highest quality reference genome
that we have
available to us uh salex vimanalis
there are two crosses here that was
chosen because salex viminalis is the
most popular species grown in europe
and a lot of those the research that i
mentioned earlier that's occurring in
europe
uses salex bim analysis and it's a known
source of
resistance to those european species of
molapsera the other
species that's used twice say like such
a wences that is the most
uh popular species that's grown in china
while the other four species
are mainly included to add diversity to
the population and
and to
catch a cast a wider net into the
diversity within celex than we could do
with just three species
so you can see the population sizes for
each of these families they range from
88
our smallest one to 150 they're all
planted
in replicated trials here in geneva
in fields that are right next to each
other they were planted at different
years
but they are written replicated trials
in geneva so within the
common parent population we have several
research questions so
it was originally designed for and the
justification for making these crosses
was
to map to identify qtl for leaf rust
resistance
but with this kind of resource we can
really do
several things with it so i'm going to
talk about those two sort of tangent
research questions
that i have and then i'll come back to
res to leaf rust resistance in
a second so i mentioned that one of the
crosses to
9401 salexproprien 941 was a salex
alberti
and this was the species identification
that
we received that larry received it was
before i got here but when what larry
received when it came from
china and he we've never really seen
salex already mentioned anywhere else
and so we're not really sure where it
fit in so
is it it's its own unique species that's
just not referenced anywhere that's not
used very often
or did someone just sort of name it and
it's
actually related to one of the other
species that we have in our population
so we wanted to figure out where salex
already fit in with the other parents
so to to do that i took all of the
gbs data that we had for all of the
populations and i've
filtered for very high quality markers i
filtered um
down to about 50 000
snips to do the
these next few analyses so
i um
generated these two separate pca so the
one on the left side of the slide
includes all the parents with the f1
progeny while the
pc on the other side includes just the
parents so we can see on
the one with the f1s our red
the red dots these are the two celix vim
analyst families with their f1s
uh the blue is the salix udensis we have
our two common parents in the middle
while the other uh this is the
salex uh koryanagi down here in the gray
while our two
salix substances integra and the alberti
are all sort of clustered together here
what this pca is really doing and what
really what we can really learn from
this
is on principal component one it's
really separating these families into
their sections so
vimenalis and eudensis are known members
of section bemin
while sachawensis integra and koryanagi
are known members of section
helix so this at least tells us from
that standpoint
that p294 is going to be in section
helix along with the salix such awensis
in the integras
when we look at a pca of just parents we
see pc1 is still
splitting along the same lines but
it does bring our two cells purporia
parents together
and really groups the parents into more
into tighter clusters
that we can see here so
taking all the multiple runs of the
parents that i had i generated a
neighbor joining tree
um which really shows um
which obviously is grouping the multiple
runs of the parents
together but we have our eudensis parent
here with the vimanalis
our two celex purpurea the koryanagi and
integra
and it's putting p294 very close to
p295 and p63 so this would
from this alone we can kind of see that
it's probably closer
to a salix such awensis but when we take
all these multiple runs of the parents
um oh excuse me
so i used the multiple runs of the
parents and randomly
selected ten individuals from
each of the uh oh excuse me
i randomly selected 10 individuals from
each of the f1 families
and ran a fast structure analysis so
fast structure
is literally i'm sure a lot of people
have heard of
structure so fast structure
fulfills the same basic goal but it's
designed to use
large gbs snip data sets
so you run the main function of fast
structure
with varying levels of k k being the
number of populations
so i ran from 3 to 10
estimated populations and then you run a
function called choose k
and choose k will go through all of the
output files that you generated
and tell you which level of k which
number of populations best
fit your data set your input files
so in the case of these families that
level of k
equals 6. so for each of the f1s
um i use purple to designate celix
purpurea so
this makes total sense that each of the
f1s are roughly 50 percent
salex purpurea well the other half
are their other parent what's worth
noting here
is that when we look at p294 it's
actually showing up as the same
population as
say like such awensis so
we we're leaning towards section helix
and then maybe it's
a such a once this hybrid but from the
results that we can see here
uh we're pretty comfortable saying that
celix alberti is actually just a
another salix such a wences and possibly
even a full sip of p295
i'm not really sure where the salex
alberti came from
but it's good to know where this parent
fits in regards to the other parents so
like i said
salex alberti p294 we're really
considering it
a salix such awensis p294
so for the next two research questions
that
i had for those populations i needed to
create linkage maps for all of the
parents so i'm going to
kind of go on a quick tangent talk about
how i
made these linkage maps and then we'll
loop back around to these research
questions
so to start out with they use the tassel
gbs version 2 discovery pipeline to call
variants
they were aligned to the salex purporia
9406
version 5.1 reference genome
this yielded between 170 to 250 000
sites depending on the family then i use
tassel to filter markers for individuals
for missing this minor allele frequency
excuse me minor allele frequency this
cut
the number of markers down to 125
000 into 200 000 then i
used a program called link computer
and yes it is link computer um i don't
know how long
i kept saying link impr but it yeah it's
link computer
uh it's a imputation algorithm that was
actually designed
to handle non-model organisms where
with greater heterozygosity than
some of the other imputation algorithms
out there
it was also um
what's unique about it is that even if a
genotype is called missing
you're still passing in the vcf file so
it accesses
the read depth on markers that were even
called
missing so what i had done with the
computer is i
set any markers that were called with a
redeploy list of five them missing
refiltered for missingness and modern
allele frequency and then imputed those
missing values
and so the vcf files that came out of
link computer
had about 90 to 150 000 sites
so taking that vcf file i then passed it
into r
to pull out the back cross markers that
i was going to use to generate these
linkage maps
so i really focused on back cross
markers
so in the case of a female back cross
marker that means it is
female informative so therefore it's
heterozygous and the female
a b by a a or male back cross where it's
male informative and this resulted in 70
so
now i'm dealing with two separate groups
of markers based on
the marker type so this generated
for the female maps there were seventy
five hundred to twenty four thousand
female back cross markers or the male
maps
there were eighty seven hundred to
twenty thousand one hundred male markers
so to actually uh construct the linkage
groups
and assess the marker order excuse me i
used a combination of rqtl and as map
so rqtl is pretty standard in qtl
mapping but as map is essentially a
r wrapper for the msc map algorithm
so i really only filtered for extreme
segregation distortion and co-location
while generating while determining those
linkage groups in the market order
so the final maps had between 21 000
3 500 female the female
back cross maps excuse me had between 21
and 3 500
while the male maps have between 2 000
and 3 900.
so i did that for all of the eight
families resulting in 16
separate linkage maps one for each
parent
um in each population so
now i can go back around to our research
questions now that i have that done
and say that one thing the last tangent
i wanted to cover
with the common parent population is to
talk about the salex integra
p336 individual so
every cross in our breeding program
that's ever used that
parent as an individual has generated
f1 that are 100 female
and this is something that larry and i
and even
brennan who is working on
sex determination have talked about
several times
uh trying to figure out possibilities
for
how this is happening so
i wanted to look at it from a view of
potentially
if it's an extreme form of sex ratio
bias or
potentially if there's something
structural about p336 where it's only
able to generate
female f1s
so i mentioned sex ratio bias so while
the 426
family uh this fifth one down from the
bottom
is 150 to zero female to male
um six out of the eight families in this
population
have some degree of sex ratio bias
all skewing toward the female and i have
i've spent a lot of time recently
reading about sex ratio bias and
everything seems to point to
um segregation distortion outside of the
sex determination region
as sort of being the culprit there
um one paper even referred to it as a
sex disorder locus
that resides outside of the traditional
sdr um
sorry uh the traditional sdr in salix
so the first thing i needed to do was i
took all of the
the sex phenotype that i had and i
mapped it
for qtl to try and figure out where the
scr is in each of these families
so naturally i was only able to find qtl
for sex
on seven of these families obviously
with the 426 family with no variation
for sex you can't map a qtl
so that's why it's only seven out of
eight what is interesting or
i should say what's worth noting is that
in each of
in the seven families the qtl for sex
occurred only in the female parent so
this makes a lot of sense uh when you
think about the sex determination
uh system for let's say salex purporia
that's a
zw system where the female is the
heterogametic sex and the male
is homozygous um it's homogeneic
because we're using female back cross
markers and that's essentially the
definition of a female back cross marker
like i said
it's female informative heterozygous and
the female
and just to provide an example this is
the peak marker from the 13x438 family
the 9406 individual that's this
plot here the third down on the right
i coded males as one females as zero
um just showing that it's a near perfect
marker these
two oddballs are likely genotyping
errors or phenotyping errors
um but it's a nearly perfect marker
showing that
all of the females are heterozygous
at that locus or at that marker excuse
me
so
kind of pivoting a bit and going back to
p336
these are all chromosome 15. i'm not
sure if i said that
all of these chromosomes are chromosome
15
and what's worth noting is that the
centimorgan distance for each of these
chromosomes ranges from like 200 to
300 centimorgans yet for the 426
family there may be only 20 markers and
roughly
35 cinemorgans so when i saw this
i
was a little freaked out because in
other
iterations of this map i had trouble
getting a stable chromosome 15
to exist at all um
so i tried several times to get
something from chromosome 15 to stick
around in that linkage map
so i really wanted to know is this
because there are fewer
female back cross markers in that
population or is it
something else um
so what i ended up doing is i went back
into r went back through my r script
and found the r files where i had typed
all of the
markers so i took
chromosome 15 and i bind it into half
megabase
bins with each of the different marker
types that i
that i found
so what's important before i keep going
with these plots is that obviously a
marker type is dependent on how the
parents aligned
together so in determining a marker type
these are the four
four families that used 9401 as the male
parent
so they had a different female parent
but they're all
these marker types are we can compare
them because
one they're all aligned to the same
male uh parent 941
so the colors on this plot are showing
in blue the male back cross markers uh
purple the female back cross markers
the gray are markers that are homozygous
but for different alleles
the green are homozygous for the same
alleles
while the yellow which there are there
is some yellow but it's
there's not very much rr intercross
markers
so um in order to
kind of narrow down the chromosome and
try and figure out where the scr
is i took the qtl from the previous
slide
for each family and put in these red
bars showing
showing the rough location of that qtl
like what is encompassed within that qtl
for sex
uh just just try and narrow down the
chromosome
and then i added this dashed line
to 426
just as like a projected sdr uh
potentially
one thing the only real conclusion that
can be drawn from these is that yes
there are fewer female back cross
markers
within the projected sdr on 13x426
for that family but in regards to
the other marker types there are
relatively consistent
numbers of markers so it's difficult to
take this data set any further to draw
any real
substantial conclusions about p336 but
what i can do
um the next steps i mentioned that there
is a paper that had identified
a sex ratio distorter locus so i
intend to use in the next couple weeks
use the methods described in that paper
to see if i can find
a a sex ratio of distorted locus
in these families one other potential
um
excuse me one other potential solve for
um the pe 336 problem is to align the
gbs reads to
genome assemblies that are currently in
production by oak ridge national labs
so they are actually creating genome
assemblies for each of the parents
within this population
so that will probably offer the greatest
potential to
figure out exactly what's going on in
p336
so to answer this research question a
definitive answer is being
on the scope of this project uh so we'll
have to
check back in later so to move on into
uh to go back to leaf rust uh lifros
severity was surveyed in these families
uh in two years 2017 and 2019
these plots are showing the eight
families within the common parent
population the families on the left side
of each figure
are those that are mated to 9406 the
families on the right are those
mated to 9401 within each plot the solid
black horizontal bar is showing the
severity of that common parent while
each black dot in a column is showing
the severity of that species that family
specific parent off parent
so you can see
depend between 2007 and 2019
there's a pretty drastic change in the
severity
uh between the years um obviously
couldn't show it but in 2018 rust
never showed up so it can be extremely
very
variable between years
and there's even quite a bit of
variation
within family for leaf rust severity
so using the 2017 leaf rest data
i was able to find three separate qtl in
three different families
so the 421 and the 407 family are the
two
salex bim analysts and these qtl were
actually found in the vimanalis parent
one was on chromosome four another was
on chromosome
three so both of these qtl are
okay let's let's be honest they're okay
there is some variation but they are
also coming
from a small amount of
um leaf rust severity but they are worth
looking into
and the last one from 2017 was found in
the 13 x 440 family the 9401 parent on
chromosome 8.
this one has a lot of um
there's still has a higher level of
a higher range over all of the frost
severity
but again they are still pretty
clustered together
with the 2019 data however i was
able to find four separate qtl for leaf
rust
the first one was on the 426 that 336
parent that i just
finished talking about on chromosome
five that one is showing
um greater variation among the
heterozygous
um allele for leaf rest severity so
anything homozygous
is lower resist um lower overall
severity to leaf rust
um well for the 10x 400
13x440 and the 13x443
all three of these families involve a
salix
setuans as parent and all of the qtl
reside on chromosome 19.
what's interesting is in two different
families but for the same
parent we were able to identify the same
qtl
the qtl in very similar regions despite
having
different levels of variation with a
variation in 443
has a lower overall level of leaf
severity
but is more variable so these qtl on
chromosome 19
offer potential um
all of the qtl that i was able to find
for leaf rest severity
offer potential for further screening
candidate trying to identify candidate
genes
or even uses marker assisted selection
down the road
so i hope to uh so these are all of the
phenotypes that i've collected
on these populations and i intend to use
to try and map
and identify qtl for every trait that i
can
on the in these populations
so the final research question do any of
the families have qtl for leaf rest
resistance yes yes they do
the second research objective for this
population
um was uh to identify qtl for resistance
for salexpropria f2 mapping population
fortunately this was taken care of
before i got here
and was published in carlson in douker
at all 2019.
use an f2 population derived from the
natural light salix purpurea
surveyed leaf rust in geneva in 2015 and
2017
and they were even able to detect
overlapping qtl
on chromosome 1
and additional qtl from a 2015 survey on
chromosomes 5
and 10. the final research objective
which uses that same f2 mapping
population
was to identify temporal gene level
responses to infection
by melancera americana within the f2
say the salexpropria f2 population
so we knew from the results of that
previous study that there
was untapped variation that we could
further describe and use in
an rna-seq experiment so that's what
this objective was really
meant to focus on so what we plan to do
is use 60 genotypes
with two experimental experimental
replicates in the greenhouse
we plan to inoculate one treatment and
use the other as an inoculated control
and sample at three separate time points
at
zero hpi which is just before
inoculation
and then again at 42 and 66 hpi
so what we actually what we ended up
doing
um after we collected the initial
time point using leaf punches we had
these really cool
little leaf punchers that had a test
tube attached to them so you could just
punch the leaf
and the disc would fall straight into a
test tube and it was
frozen um nearly almost immediately with
liquid nitrogen
in the greenhouse but we would collect
six to eight leaf punches
per leaf
and after the initial collection for
xero hpi
both control and inoculated treatment
spent 12 hours in a missed chamber
where we before which we had brush
inoculated
the inoculated treatment and flagged
those leaves with blue flagging tape as
you can see in this picture here
so using
excuse me using the 2015 and 2017 lefre
severity data that they had used to map
qtl
in the calcium and the carlson and
gaucher paper
we selected 28 resistant and 28
susceptible f2 genotypes based on those
two surveys
in addition to the parents and
grandparents of that f2 population
nine days after each greenhouse rep
chase crawl went in and rated leaf rust
severity
um in each population so he's also the
one who
did all of the raiding well he and chris
smart
did the leaf rest severity rating
for the qtl that i mentioned earlier i
should have said that then
as yes so they were the ones who
did the leaf rust rating in the fields
and chase is the one who did the rating
in the greenhouse in the exact
using the same kind of style scale
rating that he did in the field so this
is just
uh two plots showing that the leaf rust
severity between our two greenhouse reps
and those reps in the field all have
moderately
significant moderate to high
correlations
also needing to mention that
the susceptible genotypes had a
significantly higher
leaf rest severity than the resistance
even though the resistant genotypes were
quite
more we're more variable in their
severity
than the susceptible ones we think this
is likely because
in the greenhouse experiment we use one
specific isolate
where in the field it could have been
that isolate and maybe
others um that were being rated on while
in the greenhouse it was just one
specific isolate
so after we collected the leaf disks
from the greenhouse
we extracted rna and sent the to the
cornell brc for three prime rna-seq
the rim is retrieved uh where the
reeds were trimmed using dramatic
they're aligned to
again the 9406 version one
version 5.1 reference genome
we got our expression count data using
htc
normalization and dec 2 and then
those normalized counts were used for
differential expression analysis
and network analysis and also eqtl
mapping in addition to all the gbs
data that they had used from the carlson
and gaucher paper
for the differential expression analysis
i effectively split it into two separate
main contrasts the first contrast was
a direct contrast between the
susceptible and then resistant genotypes
in order to do this i split the samples
into six
time point by treatment groups um
that way i could rule out any
differentially expressed genes that were
present at zero hbi or in the control
treatment allowed me to have more
control
over which differentially expressed
genes um
were relevant or we could see so what
this allowed me to do
was to identify those different to
express genes that were either
upregulated in the resistant genotypes
upregulated in the susceptible genotypes
the second contrast was between
treatments inoculated versus control
so the samples were split into six time
point by type
groups so this um again i ruled out
different
express genes whether or not based on
whether or not
they were present at zero hpi
and then these were sorted into type
specific or not type specific
uh differentially expressed genes and
i'll explain
that in just one second so
results of the direct contrast between
susceptible and resistant
there were very few genes that were
differently expressed at 42 hpi
um there were only six that were up
regulated among the resistant
just to to give some examples there was
a polyubiquity in 10
plasma membrane intrinsic protein and a
phosphoglycerate kinase one all of which
have been implicated
in disease resistance um
while those that were upregulated among
the susceptible
uh several of them were involved in the
flavonoid synthesis pathway
when we get to 66 hpi we had a there
were more differently expressed genes
again
most of the ones up regulated among the
resistant could be classified as your
usual suspects
for disease resistance while those among
the
upregulated among the susceptible
genotypes
showed enrichment for response to heat
stress or reactive oxygen
species so one thing that
was obvious to me is that compared to
other papers when there's a direct
contrast between susceptible and
resistant we're dealing with
smaller log full changes than what i had
seen
in some other systems or some other
papers
so my initial reasoning for this is that
perhaps
this this is an f2 population things are
going to be closely related
and based on the qtl
paper that um the paper i keep
referencing with
the carlson and gauker paper um
we could tell that they had identified
three qtl
with the expectation in that paper that
there are likely others that they
weren't able to
detect summarizing or concluding that
it's likely a multi-genic
resistance so if we think about
smaller log full changes smaller effect
genes
we're not dealing with anything major
effect it's just
a small amount a large number of small
changes in expression that could lead to
a difference between
a compatible or an incompatible
interaction
looking at the um
the results between inoculated and
control
again i split these differently
expressed genes
into resistance specific susceptible
specific
and not type specific so what i meant
when i said that earlier
is that in a resistance specific
difference expressed genes that means
that it was differently expressed in the
only the resistant genotypes and not in
the susceptible ones
and vice versa for the susceptible
specific if something is
if something is called a not type
specific difference to express gene
that means obviously that it was
differentially expressed in both the
resistant and the susceptible genotypes
so what these plots are showing it's
relating the log full changes between
the resistant on the y axis and the
susceptible on the x
and grouping them into their
type specific log full change
difference so
in the three groups that were enriched
that were in the positive log full
change resistant
specific susceptible specific and not
type specific
all three of those groups were enriched
for defense response so already at 42
hours post inoculation
we see a common defense response
between both the resistance and the
susceptible genotypes but we also see us
specific defense responses we already
see
some differences at that level
in response to treatment between the
resistant and the susceptible genotypes
well um in the negative log full change
decreasing
uh log full change
uh those the resistance specific and the
susceptible specific were really only
released
enriched for chloroplast components
um not full photosynthesis just yet but
just chloroblast components
but by the time we get to 66 hpi
we have a lot more genes being engaged
our log full changes are increasing
things are really starting to ramp up
but we see that only the resistance
specific and not
type specific positive log full change
groups
those two are the only two groups that
have
retained that enrichment for defense
response so our susceptible genotypes
and our positive log full changes have
lost some of those unique
uh defense response genes
we also see that now um
and i should have put this on here but
now we can see in the negative
log full changes all three of these
groups
that's a lie i'm sorry the resistance
specific and not type specific
negative log full changes are the only
ones that are enriched for
photosynthesis
related terms so it's pretty common to
see in the literature
that uh in studies like this where there
is some
exchange between uh promoting a defense
response
and photosynthetic efficiency in use
you know a plant has a finite number of
resources
and so in a more coordinated response
you would see a drop in photosynthesis
that corresponds to an increase in
that defense response so at this stage
we can already see
um see that playing out
i'm sorry i just looked at the time um
the next analysis that we have is a
network analysis
um these samples were split into two
separate groups
uh resistant and susceptible inoculated
um
i
a network analog the our package i used
for network analysis was wg
cna it's a weighted weighted gene
coexpression network analysis it
essentially takes gene expression
from your whole entire rna-seq data set
and
forms them into co-expression modules
that have a common
variation through your data set i use
the hyper geometric test to combat
comparisons between the two groups
the two separate networks that i
developed and
use the plug-in cyto hubba inside escape
to calculate
connectedness metrics that i used to
determine hub genes
so i wanted to figure out which modules
were most related to
time uh to try and see if i could find
any that were constantly increasing or
decreasing depending on
the time point and this helped me narrow
down
in the resisted network to the turquoise
module which had
a 0.92 positive correlation with
a time point it was also the only module
on the resistant network that was
enriched for defense related terms
the blue module had a negative .89
correlation it's the second largest
module
and it again was the only resistant
module that was enriched for
photosynthesis related terms
so based on the results of the
differential expression analysis i knew
i wanted to focus
on um that partitioning of resources
that
um kind of exchanged between defense
response and photosynthesis
so i used a hypergeometric test which is
essentially the same sort of analysis
that a
go enrichment analysis
genometology enrichment analysis uses i
used the susceptible network as the
background so each gene
was tied to a specific module and i use
the turquoise and blue modules as the
input list
to be able to basically tie a p-value
to each set of modules
so the turquoise module was
significantly tied to four separate
it basically split into four where the
susceptible turquoise and the
susceptible salmon modules are the only
two that
retained enrichment for those defense
related terms so we see that
module shrinking but also splitting in
two
while the resistant blue module split
into
effectively shattered into six separate
susceptible modules
however only two of those modules the s
brown and s
red kept enrichment for those
photosynthetic related terms
so i seeing how
those full modules were basically split
into smaller modules
and a susceptible group it got me
thinking about the role of hub genes
in each of these networks so a hub gene
is considered the most connected or
structurally important genes within that
module
and they're predicted to have a
regulatory influence
over the remaining genes
so what i had done is i had
basically identified the hub genes for
each of these
those four modules that i talked about
where you have the
resistant turquoise and the resi and the
susceptible turquoise module
in each of these plots the bars
on the outer side are the two or the hub
genes
at that time point um their average
expression
related to the shared number of genes so
in the case of the two turquoise modules
from the different networks
they share 3 500 genes
but they are controlled by different
numbers of hub genes that's related to
the size of that overall module
so in the in respect to time and i'm
very sorry that i've gone over
i will just highlight this
one plot here and show that
the turquoise modules at t0 they're all
equal the hub genes
the average hub gene average expression
of hub genes is equal to
the average expression of the rest of
the genes in the module but as time goes
on
and those defense response genes are
starting to kick in we see that the
resistant
hub genes of the resistant module are
actually expressing significantly
greater
on average than the hub genes of the
susceptible module
so what this told me was that even
though
we might have not have had so many
genes that were significantly
differentially expressed
between the resistant and the
susceptible genotypes
there was still other a common response
between the two groups but the resistant
genotypes were responding that much
faster
and just that much more um
on average so that's 3500 genes
that are expressing just that much more
in the resistant genotypes than those
exact same genes are
in a susceptible group
so briefly on the photosynthesis side
the hub genes that are controlling those
genes are gradually decreasing through
time
even though it's having a very small
effect on
those shared genes
we still see that sort of trade-off
between the increase and the decrease
based on
whether it's defense response or
photosynthesis
so i only have a few slides left again
i'm really sorry that i've gone over
the eqtl mapping i split the samples
into six
separate time point by treatment groups
ruled out eqtl based on whether they
were present
before inoculation or in the control
treatment
and in order to call something a hot
spot i had
i ran a permutation test on the maximum
number of genes
that can associate with a single snip by
chance
to get a permuted threshold
so through these methods at 42 and 66
hpi i identify eight hot spots
at 42 each one
noted by these letters and six
hot spots at 66 hpi unfortunately none
of these
hot spots were specifically enriched for
defense-related terms
but several of the e-genes within each
hot spot
are your usual suspects in terms of
defense response
there are also some of those some of the
genomic regions of that hot spot
actually are nearby um
some of these defense response genes
so in order to identify candidate genes
in this study
i looked at the intersection of genes
that were differentially expressed
genes that were that are hub genes for
the
resistant blue or turquoise modules and
also those genes that are associated
with an eqtl hotspot
and so this created a list of 124
candidate genes
and i just pulled out a few examples
a cap super family protein wall
associated kinase
or udp glucosyl transferase
gene all of which these three have the
um most significant correlation with
leaf
severity of the candidate genes
so the takeaways from this presentation
i was able to identify several qtl
associated with leaf rest resistance
so these could be used as potential
targets to identify
candidate genes or even for future
development for marker assisted
selection
um numerous uh several of these families
have
uh produced f1 individuals that
are now being used in yield trials and
for breeding
um and also was able to isolate 124
candidate genes
that can be potential targets for qrt
pcr validation in the future
so i want to thank everyone for
sticking around um thank everyone in the
larry smart lab pastor president with a
special shout out to
craig carlson and eric fabia who
answered a lot of my dumb questions
um holly and chris from chris smart lab
uh
a special shout out from their lab to
chase who was really kind of my partner
in crime
and everything related to leaf rust and
he's
i feel like we've helped each other a
lot along the way and i really
appreciate
him and i'd also like to thank my
graduate committee which is obviously
larry smart
chris smart bruce reich and michael gore
so thank you
thanks very much dustin great job uh we
have a few minutes for
questions here but i'll just mention
chris and i have to leave at 1 30 to go
get our vaccination
so you can either unmute and ask your
question directly or type it in the chat
whichever you
prefer so
i will just start with a question dustin
i'm
very intrigued uh by the resistance
genes that map to chromosome 19.
we're kind of desperately trying to
identify
a loci that may be involved in
sex dimorphism and chromosome 19 is the
location of the sex determination region
in poplar so
i'll ask the question do we see any
sexual dimorphism
for rust resistance
in salix and maybe
if so maybe there's an interaction there
between
the evolution of daishi and sex
dimorphism for rust
do we see any sex dimorphism for rust
resistance so i have had i've heard
mixed reviews on
depending on who that talk to if i'm
being honest
um in this data set i don't um
in this population i don't see any
relationship between sex and
refreshed resistance um
that's really all i can speak to
yeah that
just again the evolutionary ties uh
in the evolution of the casey are very
interesting with the movement of the sex
determination region
uh between 15 and many of our salic
species
19 and poplar and chromosome 7
on other sailors species uh
so there is a question in the chat from
shittay is the qtl on chromosome 19
contributed by the heterozygous parent
sorry i was i i stopped sharing my
slides so i just went back and look it
looks like it is
uh contributed by the um
heterozygous parents so in the 9401 map
the male is the heterozygous
it's a male informative marker so it
would be contributed by the heterozygous
parent so it is coming from
9401 it's mapping back to 9401.
other questions
well certainly you see that uh dustin
still has a little more
analysis to do all those other traits
that we mapped in our
f1 common parent populations that's
going to yield a lot of interesting
results
uh his data are feeding right into our
nsf-funded project on
sex determination so that's great and
we'll help out brandon a lot
and uh he's uh on a solid foundation to
start contributing to our hemp uh
breeding program
after he graduates this summer so thanks
again very much dustin thanks everyone
for
joining us today and have a great day
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu